foreign
[Music]
good morning it's currently 3 58 a.m on
a Monday let's start the day
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
while I was planning to film myself I'm
right now
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]
so lovey what is considered first line
treatment with generalized seizures
[Music]
well one of those I think
okay let's see it's sodium valparais but
carbomazepine Coastline for focal
features so it's not bad at all nice
we're here at the hospital right now
what time is it right now Lavi 7 23 a.m
in the morning and this is the hospital
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how are you feeling about your first day
back at medical school as a fourth year
apprehensive but I'm sure it'd be fine
once we get back into the swing I think
what about up how do you feel I'm very
excited to be back had a great summer
and I'm ready to go I'm excited to get
back into a routine and feel like I have
something to do
I'm feeling a bit tired but it should be
good it should be good yeah thank you
currently we're just waiting for our
placement to start
I'm too embarrassed to like put it all
up and we're just waiting for our
placement to start what time is it it's
right 45 so yeah 15 minutes left I'll
keep you guys updated
there's the room that we're going to be
in we're just waiting for the doctor to
arrive right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Caleb morning was good I had some good
teaching
um I was very hungry so happy to be on
lunch good morning really interesting
teaching with the diabetic nurse and a
lot about insulin and all of that that
was interesting
panda
[Music]
thank you
I just went to the toilet but now I
can't find my way back to the library
one of the fifth years helped me find my
way to the toilet anyway and now I can't
get back to the library
hiya
hey sorry
do you know the weight of the
hi sorry do you know the way to the
library
that way thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how was yourselina
it's okay
[Music]
I need to be more professional Caleb how
was your day day was good A bit chaotic
being in the first day
um it seems like the hospital isn't used
to the amount of students but I'm sure
they'll get accustomed to it and so will
we yeah exactly you're more hopeful on
the camera than you are off camera that
is accurate yeah
why are you telling the people which
employer could be watching
hello
[Music]
[Laughter]
tiny Hospital compared to Cornwall but
even if it's like shiny no it was so
tiny it is so small but there's really
interesting cases how was your day
wrestler your first day back at med
school finding my way around a new
hospital was a bit tricky at first but I
had my partners to go with so that was
quite nice
okay and now we're going to little to do
some shopping and I'll see you guys
there and she was like going into so
much detail about anatomy and stuff not
showing off our knowledge but like kind
of showing off her knowledge
[Music]
um
keep going keep going I'm not gonna get
any shopping done
[Music]
[Music]
stop following me oh my God it's even
there with you
[Music]
the reality of student eating if you ask
me
especially on the same table but if I
sit there I would not be able to see
because of all the crap in between
Caleb was so good my new placement
partner is like the best person ever hey
he's so comfortable with me
yeah of course all of you are hello it's
currently 8 42. I've had such a long day
but I think it was a good first day back
at medical school so we had an
endocrinology clinic in the morning I
got to see patients with different
hormone related problems like thyroid
hormone diseases or adrenaline hormone
diseases and I got to examine a patient
with a goiter which is like very big
swollen neck her thyroid gland which is
the gland that sits on your neck was
very swollen and examining her was very
helpful for my learning in the afternoon
though we didn't have any clinic so I
was just in the library doing practice
questions for my upcoming exam but the
worst thing about having to commit three
hours a day for my Hospital placements
is the fact that I come home so late and
I don't have any energy or time to do
any work before it goes to sleep and
that is the situation I'm in right now
I'm just gonna go do my skincare and get
ready for bed if I feel awake enough
then I might do some work but I'm not
gonna force myself because we'll need to
be driving at 6am tomorrow morning as
well so let's see how I feel
[Music]
okay in the end I did some practice
questions on Endocrinology for like half
an hour but I hope you guys enjoyed my
first day back at medical school if you
did consider subscribing and liking this
video and I'll see you in the next one
bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]